[Musica]
questa è la storia di come la vita di
uno scrittore
sia stata trasformata radicalmente
dal l'impulso alla generosità radicale e
di come
l'urgenza
della guerra sia diventata instant karma
lo scrittore è davanti a voi la persona
che vi sta parlando in questo momento
ora però prima di
arrivare al punto in cui voglio portarvi
vi prego di pensare a david bowie
c'è una canzone di david bowie che si
chiama time al minuto
2.11 di time
david bowie si ferma un attimo la musica
si ferma un attimo e ci sono circa tre
secondi della voce di bolca respira e fa
poi riprende la musica è una delle più
belle ballate pianistiche mai scritte
essendo dinamismo
50 anni dopo in una canzone che si
chiama tease pt chiusa all
david bowie già malato
introduce la sua una delle sue ultime
canzoni che registra nella sua vita con
un altro respiro respiro di una l'uomo
più anziano prossimo alla morte
ed è un respiro diverso che più o meno
fa così
il respiro come sapete è una parte
fondamentale
della filosofia buddista
attraverso il respiro si può arrivare a
quello che i buddisti chiamano
liberazioni in vita attraverso
un modo importante di respirare e
consapevole di respirare si può arrivare
a liberare la propria anima in vita
rendendo ma uno dei grandi scrittori del
ventesimo secolo è uno dei grandi
maestri del pensiero esoterico del xxi
secolo
ha scritto poco prima di morire questa
breve mandala che dice sono morto perché
non ho desiderio non ho desiderio perché
credo di possedere
credo di possedere perché non cerco di
dare
cercando di dare si vede che non si è
niente vedendo che non si sa niente
vedendo che non si sa niente
si cerca di dare se stessi cercando di
dare se stessi si vede che non si è
niente
vedendo che non si sa niente
si cerca di divenire desiderando
divenire divina
ora
negli ultimi 80 nove giorni
io ho capito differenza tra vivere e di
venire
gli ultimi tanto nove giorni rispetto al
momento in cui vi parlo attualmente
quando qualcuno vedrà questo video
saranno altrettanto nove giorni altre 89
giorni parlo dei primi tre mesi della
guerra di invasione russa e ucraina
i miei figli son per metà ucraini e
quindi ho una ragione personale
per sentire che l'ucraina il mio secondo
paese
ma al di là della regione personale
credo che ci siano stati tanti umani in
europa in america nel mondo
e soprattutto in ucraina che abbiano
sentito che questi mesi queste settimane
siano state un atto di trasformazione
radicale
credo che la brutalità il morale di
questa guerra si possa vedere negli
effetti altamente morali calma mucche
che essa ha avuto una le vite di molte
persone
devo dirvi che fino a questi mesi
io non avevo mai coltivato un ideale che
andasse molto al di là di quello che era
la un ideale di cercare di fare bene
proprio lavoro di occuparsi dei propri
figli di cercare di non incutere terrore
inutilmente nelle persone quelle cose
normali insomma che si cerca di fare che
non sempre si riescono a fare non sto
parlando di grandi ideali appunto
gli ultimi mesi io ho cercato di
dedicarli principalmente a aiutare le
persone che arrivavano dall ucraina
abbiamo cercato di aiutare persone che
stavano lì non cercato di aiutare anche
alcuni dissidenti che scappano dalla
russia queste persone
c'è un solo modo per averci a che fare
veramente avendo provando ad avere il
proprio cuore bagnato dalle lacrime di
queste persone
non è facile perché sono persone
spaventate
offese
ferite
deboli
non è facile avere a che fare con
persone deboli spaventate ferita non
sono di solito il meglio dell'umanità
credo che
avere a che fare con persone deboli
spaventate e ferite però sia un modo di
far crescere un albero dentro la propria
pelle
coltivare un ideale si dice
avere a che fare con persone deboli
spaventate ferite
ti porta a pensare che vero tesoro
dell'esperienza umana non si sa
come avevo sempre pensato occupandomi di
cultura di arte letteratura
il momento in cui la curva di un genio
del genio produce opere immortali
gli ultimi quartetti di beethoven
i due anni in cui vito sono passati a
essere da un gruppo pop a un gruppo
d'avanguardia crescita per sempre nella
storia della musica i quattro romanzi di
philip roth dopo pastorale americana e
clima
ecco ho capito che queste cose sono
molto importanti sono il motivo per cui
scriviamo perché andiamo a vedere un
museo perché amiamo la musica
forse il motivo per cui viviamo forse
sola cosa più bella che l'essere umano
possa produrre però c'è una cosa ancora
più importante ed è la curva di
accelerazione del cambiamento e si
produce quando una persona spaventata
debole ferite
in qualche modo guarisce
e questo tipo di
operazione di guarigione che
difficilissima perché queste persone
possono essere molto difficili persone
che sono state sotto i bombardamenti
diaz dalle persone che sono state sotto
i bombardamenti di kharkiv persone che
sono sopravvissute a situazioni tali per
cui potrebbero essere anche delle
persone non tanto carine in assoluto
ecco c'è però un modo che una forma che
alcuni chiamano a quella della
generosità radicale non si generosità
radicale significa dare di più di quello
che si sa come diceva rené daumal
capisci che tu non sei niente e cerchi
di dare tutto e cerchi dare tutto se
stesso e soltanto così intrigue quella
strana risonanza che permette al cuore
di far bagnare
di essere bagnato con le lacrime di
un'altra persona ecco
io avevo passato tutta la vita a dire
parole scrivere
che dire che proviene dall ascoltare per
esempio un'opera d'arte da commentarla
oggi ho capito che la vera differenza
non è tra il dire e il fare
ma tra il dire e dare
ho capito che queste persone mi hanno
messo davanti non solo un esempio di
coraggio straordinario
persone che all'improvviso hanno
lasciato tutto nella propria della
propria vita 25 26 a 40 anni a 50 anni
persone che in alcuni casi
hanno salvato qualcun altro che non
conoscevano nemmeno
ho capito però che a un certo punto la
cosa veramente importante era che
vivere per i libri vivere per la musica
scrivere
era un modo di stare leggermente
laterale laterali rispetto alla vita
a che avere a che fare con queste
persone trovargli un alloggio a
risolvere infiniti problemi
continuamente senza spesso ricevendo
ringraziamenti a volte non riceve un
ricevendo nulla a volte addirittura
inimicandosi delle persone
ecco questo mi ha messo in una
situazione di
trasformazione dell'anima la dico in
maniera un po retorica o di
trasformazione dell'abito
dell'abito della vita che mi ha portato
molto più vicino alla vita e devo dirvi
che per chi scrive per chi fa il lavoro
intellettuale
a volte essere di lontani dalla vita può
essere un po un problema è anche però
una specie di difetto inevitabile
soltanto stando un po lontani riesce
veramente a trovare le parole giuste
talvolta tuttavia stare troppo lontani
può portare a sentire una specie di
decelerazione del proprio battito vitale
e a un certo punto ti rendi conto che
non stai più vivendo che non coincide
più con te stesso ora in questi
nelle settimane che precedono il momento
più visto parlando ci sono stati tali e
tante emergenze sofferenze a volte
indicibili a volte indecenti per quello
che è successo
bambini che guardano davanti al muro
e non riescono alzare gli occhi dal
proprio cagnolino che hanno salvato
attraverso operazioni molto complicate
donne che
arrivano ogni una casa accoglienza e
rubano il latte dalle altre donne perché
in qualche modo si sentono più
intitolate alla sofferenza
cose anche meravigliose che sono
successe tipo persone che hanno comprato
degli appartamenti
potendolo fare per ospitare i profughi
questo successo a torino
ecco tutto questo a un certo punto mi ha
fatto sentire vivo come non ero mai
stato prima e mi ha fatto capire che
forse la vera opera come ricevere per
rendendo male al punto non è scritta ma
in qualche modo di uno spazio strano tra
la vita e la scrittura
e
il mod
questo questo stare di uno spazio strano
tra la vita e la scrittura a un certo
punto mi ha portato a fare una scelta
molto importante
che avverrà
domani rispetto a quando sto parlando in
questo momento ma per chi avrà visto
questo video probabilmente farà già
successa che è partire per l'ucraina
e organizzare il primo evento culturale
con ospiti internazionali presenti
fisicamente in ucraina da quando è
scoppiata la guerra
questo
credo che sia il modo più giusto per
avvicinarsi a quel respiro di cui
parlavo prima
il respiro di davy boy giovane del fiore
di david bowie vecchio il respiro che ti
porta liberarti in vita e che porta il
tuo cuore a bagnarsi veramente nelle
lacrime della persona che soffrono
abbiamo capito che l'unico modo per fare
cultura veramente per coltivare un
ideale cultura coltivazione
e anche rituale quindi per questo
ufficiale o virtuale della cultura in un
luogo di sofferenza mettere il proprio
corpo là dove avviene la sofferenza dove
c'è anche un pericolo
ecco ho capito che non solo era la cosa
giusta da fare ma era l'unica cosa
possibile da fare e allora abbiamo messo
insieme un gruppo di appunti
intellettuali direttori di musei
architetti musicisti
internazionali di vari paesi e abbiamo
organizzato questa cosa molto complessa
da un punto di vista logistico ma che
alla vigilia della partenza e spero che
questo sia confermato anche dopo
gli sembra l'unica cosa giusta
avrò fatto in tutta la mia vita insieme
for server
diciamo data la non aiutata a narra la
voce miei figli
credo che essere lì essere dove la
sofferenza arriva essere in qualche modo
in questo atto di trasformazione che ha
passa attraverso la cultura ma passa
anche attraverso dare
la più alta forma di
coincidere con se stessi che finora io
abbia mai provato e penso che
questo mo abbia tanto a che fare col
fatto che con legame di sangue
penso che questo abbia a che fare col
fatto di
aiutare a coltivare un ideale che più
alto e le più importante e va al di là
di se stessi
per vissuto fuori dalla storia e perfino
fuori dalla vita prima di incontrare
tutto questo dolore è un certo punto
fare una promessa me stesso non sarò mai
più
indifferente a questo parola grazie
[Applauso]